>> Tucker: HAVING CONVINCED
POOR JEFF LIKE TO WEEKLONG
INVESTIGATION, JUDGE KAVANAUGH
SOMEBODY SCRUBBED IT IN AN
ELEVATOR WHICH IS HOW DEMOCRACY
WORKS NOW.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT TRYING TO
DICTATE THE SCOPE OF THE
INVESTIGATION AS IF THEY ARE IN
CHARGE OF CONGRESS WHICH THINGS
TO JEFF FLAKE THEY ARE.
IN A LETTER RELEASED TODAY,
DEMOCRATS HAVE CALLED TO THE
BUREAU TO INVESTIGATE ALL THREE
A LA ALLEGATIONS AGAINST BRETT
KAVANAUGH INCLUDING JULIE'S
FANTASY ABOUT GANG RAPED.
AT A BARE MINIMUM ABOUT THEIR
ALLEGATIONS, NOT QUITE AS
IMPRESSIVE.
HE JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
PROFESSOR, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON.
ARE WE RIGHT TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MISLED WHEN DEMOCRATS AND PUBLIC
TOLD US ON FRIDAY, THREE DAYS
LATER, THAT THEY WANT CHRISTINE
FORD'S ALLEGATIONS INVESTIGATED
FOR A WEEK AND NOW THE GOALPOSTS
ARE SO FAR DOWN THE FIELD WE
CAN'T SEE THEM.
SHOULD WE POKE WE HAVE BEEN LIED
TO?
>> I THINK THE LEAST CONVINCING
PART OF THE DEMOCRATIC CASE IS
THAT THIS WAS NOT BEING
MANIPULATED IN TERMS OF ITS
TIMING.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
THESE ALLEGATIONS WERE HELD TO
THE LAST MINUTES.
RIGHT BEFORE THE VOTE.
I THINK THERE IS A LEGITIMATE
CRITICISM FOR THAT.
ALSO I THINK YOU WANT TO
ANTICIPATE THAT ONE WEEK IS NOT
GOING TO STRATIFY MANY OF THE
CRITICS.
THE FACT IS THAT MOST OF THESE
STATEMENTS, NOT ALL OF THEM WERE
PREVIOUSLY GIVEN TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE UNLIKELY TO CHANGE AND
SO THE OUTCOME OF THIS
INVESTIGATION IS UNLIKELY TO
CHANGE MANY MINDS.
WE ARE GOING TO GET TO A POINT
WHERE WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION.
IF SENATORS FILL AT THE RECORD
IS INSUFFICIENT THEY HAVE A
REASON I SUPPOSED TO VOTE ON
THAT BASIS.
TO KEEP THIS OPEN INDEFINITELY,
IT IS GOING TO DO AN INJUSTICE
TO THE NOMINEE AND TO THE
PROCESS.
WE HAVE TO COME TO SOME
CONCLUSION.
>> Tucker: JULIE SPUTNIK'S
CLAIMS THAT THEY WERE A SERIES
OF AT LEAST TEN GANG RAPE'S THAT
TOOK PLACE, NOBODY'S EVER HEARD
THIS AND IT HAS NEVER BEEN
ALLEGED.
DO YOU THINK THIS RISES TO THE
LEVEL OF CREDIBILITY THAT WOULD
SPUR AN FBI INVESTIGATION ALMOST
40 YEARS LATER?
>> SUMS UP THE FBI IS NOT GOING
TO INVESTIGATE THAT ALLEGATION.
PART OF THE CONCERN FOR MANY
PEOPLE IS THAT THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY ALLEGATION WITH NO
ONE GOING TO THE POLICE.
PREVIOUSLY OR ANY ACCOUNTS BEING
PUBLISHED AS TO WHAT OCCURRED.
FOR THAT REASON I THINK THE FBI
IS FOCUSING ON THE EARLIER TWO
ALLEGATIONS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU EXPECT THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL BE ABLE TO
REASSERT CONTROL?
>> Martha: I THINK THEY DO RUN
THE SENATE.
IF IN ENOUGH TIME, MARK JUDGE
HAS BEEN INTERVIEWED AGAIN UNDER
OATH.
WE ARE DONE.
CAN THEY DO THAT?
>> OF COURSE THAT CAN AND IT
DOES APPEAR THAT McCONNELL WAS
GOING TO PUSH THIS THROUGH.
HE SAID THERE'S GOING TO BE A
VOTE OF THIS WEEK.
THE TIMING IS A LITTLE BIT
CURIOUS BECAUSE THE FBI WAS
GIVEN A FULL WEEK THAT WOULD END
ON FRIDAY PRESUMABLY A LOT OF
MATERIAL WOULD BE GIVEN TO THE
SENATE ON FRIDAY.
IT IS NOT QUITE CLEAR HOW THE
LOGISTICS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN